the leader of the operation literally
and figuratively has run away from the
judgment of the for the third time mr.
speaker he's turned down our offer to
get brexit done it's vital the fact that
he and every member of his party have
stood on a promise to deliver brexit in
this Parliament and I think frankly that
the electorate will find his behavior
utterly bewildering but as I said we're
moving the motion we will not allow this
paralysis to continue in one way or
another we must proceed straight to an
election so later on this evening the
government will give notice of
presentation for a short bill for an
election on the 12th of December so that
we can finally get brexit done and this
is there is no support in that in the
house and we've heard earlier on from
the benches opposite for the web to
proceed but mr. speaker this house
cannot any longer keep this country
hostage millions of families and
businesses cannot plan for the future
and and I don't believe that this
paralysis and this stagnation should be
allowed to continue now that no deal is
off the table
we have a great new deal we have a great
new deal and it's time for the voters to
have a chance to pronounce on that deal
and to enter replace this dysfunctional
Parliament with a new Parliament that
can get breaks it done so the country
can move on
[Applause]